since the start of the pandemic what was once
thought to have been a baby bust may have actually
been a baby bump a study from Northwestern
University has found that birth rates in the
U.S declined slightly as lockdowns began in
early 2020 but rose again in 2021 to create a
net increase of 46 000 births above pre-pandemic
levels the pandemic has been a stressful time
to give birth and deal with the challenges of
becoming a new parent but that can be tough even
in the best of times and many believe the United
States doesn't provide sufficient time or care
for brand new moms to adjust now some are pushing
for new Solutions and new attitudes towards this
critical time of life I love you about five weeks
after her baby was born Elena Weir checked into
Boram inside a five-star hotel in New York City
the luxury Retreat is a getaway for new parents
complete with a staff Nursery comfortable rooms
meals and workshops now there are some babies who
have reflux all designed to help moms and their
Partners adjust to Parenthood we go from taking
care of ourselves to completely forgetting about
ourselves or not having time for ourselves so I
think it's a big shift and then just coming here
and even being able to physically heal to take
that time and have mental space for ourselves
again and just ease into it and just have that
support which I think is just really nice in
the U.S moms leave the hospital one to two
days after giving birth they often don't receive
maternal support until the traditional six-week
postpartum visit abroad many cultures prescribe
a 30 to 40-day period of rest in Korea and other
places like Taiwan it's Unthinkable not to check
in to a place like this after you give birth Suk
Park and his wife Boram Nam opened Boram earlier
this year inspired by similar Korean Retreats our
mission is really to make the postnatal care
essential and we begin doing so by raising the
awareness and start providing a solution right
through the services that we provide but a stay
like this is Out Of Reach for most with a price
tag around fifteen hundred dollars a night do
you think it's possible that can become more
affordable absolutely absolutely all the urban
areas should have something like this and across
multiple price points yeah we should be able
to stay a place like this for under 500 which is
roughly the the price for uh you know what a night
nurse would charge the first six weeks following
childbirth have been called the fourth trimester
a time that has lasting physical and mental health
implications for both moms and their newborns do
we need to do a better job after a woman gives
birth in really checking in to see how she's
doing absolutely Dr Catherine monk is a professor
of medical psychology at Columbia University one
of her focuses is maternal mental health how
prevalent is postpartum depression yeah you know
it's really prevalent in fact 10 to 15 percent of
women and that can actually be doubled when you're
looking at women who are experiencing poverty so
it's really common she says care for new moms is
more comprehensive and in other countries where
women have access to midwives or other Supportive
Services countries are particularly Australia
way ahead of us England has mother baby units
and then frankly countries that have managed this
challenge of healthcare economics just have it a
bit better than we do because there aren't so
much disparities in who has access to what kind
of care based on what kind of insurance and things
like that Medicaid the public health insurance
program for people with low income pays for 42
percent of all births in the U.S some states
only offer pregnancy-related Medicaid coverage
for 60 days after childbirth though more than
half expanded that coverage to 12 months after
the passage of the American Rescue plan act in
2021. I decided to do a postpartum depression
advocacy and Comedy Tour a national tour in a
bright pink 40-foot bus because I want to
get people's attention everybody [Music]
Angelina Spicer is leading a national
campaign to lobby for better care for new moms
I pushing my daughter out
I was like I made a mistake
my body but I lost my mind inspired by her
postpartum Journey which included a stop in
a psychiatric ward you know the psych ward was
not the ideal place for me to be I was the only
mom there I was the only black woman there it was
a culmination of how I felt as a mom misunderstood
depressed sad searching for Community searching
for understanding searching for connection I
thought that I was gonna get that there I
didn't get that but what I did get was sleep
I got sleep I got meds and I got someone every
15 minutes asking me hey Angeline are you okay
concerned about you not just the baby concerned
about me and I needed that when I first had Ava I
went on a 10-day vacation to this amazing Resort
in Pasadena called the licensina psychiatric
facility [Applause] I call it the Waldorf
hysteria did you have any hesitation of maybe
I should maybe this is one of those areas where
I shouldn't go or joke my mom told me she's like
you're gonna joke about postpartum you're gonna
joke about the psych ward you're going to joke
about intrusive thoughts right and I love my mom
so I hesitated because she said it and I was like
well mommy this is funny okay and big Burly dudes
are in the comedy clubs laughing and dming me
there's freedom on the other side of these jokes
freedom to push for Meaningful change Spicer was
part of an effort in California that got three
bills related to maternal Health passed helping
to change the screening process and Aid those most
in need the onus can't fall on the mom's shoulders
to Rally herself to it begin to explain the
intrusive thoughts she might be having the
depressive mood that she might be feeling the
sleepless nights the onus can't be on the mother
it needs to be on the medical professional to
initiate these conversations and initiate the
support that's out there my postpartum depression
and anxiety was almost immediate Spicer is also
working on a documentary about her own experiences
in the spring she'll be on the road again taking
her bus and her comedy around the country all in
an effort to erase the stigma around postpartum
mood disorders and rally for better care for
moms so where are you now with motherhood
I'm deep in this thing this is the dream I'm I
feel like I'm living the motherhood dream now
I felt like the cloud began to lift when my
daughter was three and that's still a long
time yeah but now that she's seven and she has
her thing I can go back to work freely and I'm
not like pumping backstage at the comedy club
I really feel like I'm in a Groove we are in a
Groove she is my best friend oh so much of this
is accessibility making it accessible to all and
this is what Angelina Spicer has been working so
hard to do make it accessible to all affordable to
all and and she is a force and she'll find a way
to get it done I am telling you I don't know what
she jokes about it it's amazing that she could
make it it's funny she found a way to make it
funny that freedom is on the other side of these
jokes right I love the conversation this opens up
and it makes people think and feel like they are
supported and have exactly exactly great story